Let’s say you want to communicate with a
friend.
You’d probably use a phone to send them
text messages.
In the same way, your brain cells communicate
using neurotransmitters like acetylcholine,
which plays a key role in processes ranging
from memory to muscle contraction.
Prompted by an electrical signal, a neuron
releases acetylcholine into the synapse.
Acetylcholine then binds to a receptor on
the opposite neuron, relaying the signal.
But what happens to acetylcholine once its
job is done?
Enter acetylcholinesterase — a dimeric enzyme
that specializes in breaking down acetylcholine
using a triad of three specific amino acids.
Zooming into the active site, we can see two
of these amino acids: the critical serine
and the histidine, to which acetylcholine
binds.
With the help of a water molecule, the enzyme
breaks acetylcholine down, completing the
signal transmission cycle.
However, as we age, the number of our cholinergic
neurons decreases, leading to reduced acetylcholine
levels and the onset of Alzheimer’s disease.
One innovative treatment for Alzheimer’s
involves inhibiting acetylcholinesterase with
molecules like galantamine, preserving the
acetylcholine in the synapse.
Galantamine blocks all entry into the active
site, allowing acetylcholine to continue its
signal transmission unscathed.
Diving into the active site, we see galantamine
shutting down operation through binding to
the critical serine.
However, because galantamine only binds through
hydrogen bonding, this inhibition is reversible.
With an estimated 5.5 million Americans living
with Alzheimer’s, understanding the biochemistry
of inhibition is a key step to bringing those
numbers down.
Finally, it’s important for individuals
consistently experiencing symptoms like confusion
and memory loss to seek a medical diagnosis
as soon as possible, giving their brains a
head start on the path to recovery.